For years, David liked playing this not so well-known board game, called Diplomacy, where he would get to do things and act in ways that he would never do in his regular life. He describes the game as a cross between Risk, poker, and the television show, Survivor. Basically, there's a map of Europe, you're assigned a country, and you're trying to take over the world.
多年来，大卫一直喜欢玩一种不太出名的棋盘游戏，叫《外交风云》（Diplomacy）。在游戏里，他可以做一些在现实生活中绝不会做的事，并以现实中绝不会有的方式行事。他将这款游戏描述为《风险》（Risk）、扑克和电视节目《幸存者》（Survivor）的结合体。简单来说，棋盘是一张欧洲地图，你会被分配到一个国家，然后试图征服世界。
There's no dice. There's no element of chance.
没有骰子。没有任何运气的成分。
And so is it about, like, bluffing and alliances, and stuff?
所以，这关乎虚张声势、结盟之类的东西吗？
Yeah. There's a lot. Alliances are key to the game, because you play with seven players. The only way for anybody to sort of overtake anyone else is for two people to team up against one.
没错。这关乎很多。结盟是游戏的关键，因为有七名玩家同时参与。任何人想要超越他人的唯一途径，就是两个人联手对抗其中一人。
Team up and attack, that is. Before each turn, there's 15 minutes where everybody negotiates with everybody else about who's going to work with whom. And then everybody goes off and writes down on pieces of paper who it is that they're going to attack. And then all the papers are read out loud, and everybody finds out who is aligned with who and who double-crossed whom. People stab each other in the back so much in this game, they don't even take the time to say the full phrase-- "stabbed in the back." Everybody just calls it "stabbing."
也就是联手进攻。每轮开始前，会有15分钟的协商时间，大家会商讨谁将与谁合作。接着，每个人离开去写下他们准备进攻的对象。随后，所有的纸条会被大声读出，每个人都会知道谁和谁结盟了，谁又背叛了谁。人们在游戏中互相背叛得太频繁了，以至于他们甚至没时间说出完整的“在背后捅一刀”（stabbed in the back）这个短语，大家都直接叫它“捅人”（stabbing）。
David played with a group of guys, his buddies, always by email. Once a week, they would email each other the next moves, which meant that the game would take months. David thought he knew what he was doing, but his friends wondered about him sometimes.
大卫总是通过电子邮件和一群朋友玩这个游戏。他们每周互发一次邮件交代下一步棋，这意味着一局游戏要花费数月时间。大卫以为自己很在行，但他的朋友们有时却对他感到疑惑。
You know, there was a time when I made, like, a pornographic Photoshop of this one player with his phone number and his social security number on it, and I told him that I was going to post it on the internet if he didn't cooperate with me. And you know, I think that some of the people in the game felt like that was-- that had crossed the line, like, that was out of bounds.
你知道，有一次我用 Photoshop 把其中一位玩家的照片处理成了一张色情图片，上面还附上了他的电话号码和社保号码，我告诉他，如果他不配合我，我就把它发布到网上。你知道，我觉得游戏里有些人觉得这——这已经过火了，超出了底线。
Wait. You took Photoshop, and you basically took his head, or face, and put it into a porno image with his social security number and--
等等。你用了 Photoshop，基本上就是把他的头或脸，放进了一张色情图片里，还加上了他的社保号码和——
--his phone number, and I think I put where he worked.
——他的电话号码，我想我还写上了他在哪里工作。
And you threatened to put that online. And you were serious?
然后你威胁要把这东西发到网上。你是认真的吗？
I don't know. I figured it would work, so I didn't know if I was bluffing or not.
我不知道。我想这样应该会奏效，所以我也不知道我当时是不是在虚张声势。
Wait, and so the people who you were playing with thought that that crossed the line. Why doesn't that cross the line?
等等，所以和你一起玩游戏的人觉得这越界了。为什么这不算越界呢？
It's definitely crossing the line. But the thing about diplomacy, I think, is kind of sick is that people will tell you nothing is out of bounds.
这绝对是越界了。但我认为《外交风云》这款游戏有点病态的地方在于，人们会告诉你没有任何事是出格的。
Well, maybe not nothing. But it's a game with a certain amount of yelling and bullying and psychological manipulation. And the boundary line is not always so clear on what you should be doing. Another time that it seemed like David might not be perceiving where that line is the same way that his opponents did. It came at the very first game that he played with other people, in person-- like not on email. He had wanted to play, in person, for years, but his buddies weren't into that. And so finally he got his chance when a friend invited him to an informal tournament in Connecticut.
好吧，也许不是没有任何事。但这确实是一个充满叫喊、欺凌和心理操纵的游戏。关于你应该做什么，界限并不总是那么清晰。另一次大卫似乎没能像对手那样察觉到界限的情况，发生在他第一次与真人面对面玩游戏的时候——而不是通过电子邮件。他多年来一直想在线下玩，但他的哥们儿对此不感兴趣。最终，当一位朋友邀请他参加康涅狄格州的一场非正式比赛时，他的机会来了。
And I was sure that I would love it. And I rode out there with him.
我当时确信我会喜欢它。我就跟他一起开车去了那里。
And so where was it? How many people?
那么是在哪里？有多少人？
It was in this weird mansion on the coast of Connecticut. And I don't know, there might have been--
那是在康涅狄格州海岸边的一座奇怪的豪宅里。我不知道，当时可能有——
Of course it was.
当然是在豪宅里。
There might have been like 50 people there, and the people were like camped out in the yard.
可能有50个人在那里，人们就像露营一样在院子里扎营。
Mhm. It was at midnight, and the wind was howling, and the lightning was striking. And--
嗯。当时是午夜，风在呼啸，闪电在闪烁。而且——
It was, like, on a cliff overlooking-- it was like--
它就像是在悬崖上，俯瞰着——就像是——
Is this true?
这是真的吗？
This is true. It was just some sort of rich family that loved Diplomacy. And so they would host people at their home. It was definitely a weird scene. It was like-- it was this really fancy house, and people all, sort of-- there were boards all over the house and out in the yard. People were all, sort of, playing Diplomacy. And the first game that I played, I was really digging it. You know, I thought, this feels good, and I feel like I can hang with these guys, and I was playing well and totally didn't feel out of my element.
这是真的。那是一户热爱《外交风云》的有钱人家。所以他们会在家里接待玩家。那场面绝对很怪异。它就像是——那是一栋非常高级的房子，到处都是棋盘，房子里、院子里到处都是。人们都在玩《外交风云》。我玩的第一局，真的玩得很投入。你知道，我想，这种感觉真不错，我觉得我能跟上这些人，而且我玩得很好，完全没有感到不自在。
Did you win?
你赢了吗？
I did not win. In fact, I stabbed a guy.
我没赢。事实上，我还捅了一个人一刀。
Stabbed a guy-- he double-crossed him. They were allies, but then David saw a way to take some of his territories, and he teamed up with a different guy against him.
捅了一个人——他背叛了对方。他们曾是盟友，但大卫看到了夺取对方一些领土的机会，于是他与另一个人联手对抗他。
And after the move was over, the guy that I stabbed wanted to talk to me. And he pulled me aside, and he says, why did you do that? And I was, like, I'm sorry, man. I didn't really think that I could work with you. I wanted to work with this other guy. And he goes, you can go fuck yourself. And he puts his finger in my face. And I said, what?
那次行动结束后，被我捅的那个人想找我谈谈。他把我拉到一边，问我：“你为什么要那么做？”我说：“我很抱歉，伙计。我真的觉得我没法和你合作。我想和另一个人合作。”他说：“你滚蛋吧。”然后把手指伸到我脸上。我说：“什么？”
And he storms over to the board and, like, knocks his stuff over and says, I quit. I'm done with this asshole. Fuck this guy. And he is storming around the house, making this big scene. Everybody in the tournament is, like, watching us.
接着他冲向棋盘，把棋子掀翻，喊道：“我不玩了。我受够了这个混蛋。操这人。”他在屋子里大吵大闹，制造了很大的动静。锦标赛里的每个人都在看着我们。
And I'm freaking out. I'm like, is this serious? Is he serious about this? And he's like, this fucking guy, and he's pointing at me and yelling. And then I watch him go around the house to every board, and like, tell the story of what just happened to his friends.
我当时吓坏了。我在想，这是认真的吗？他是真这么生气吗？他大喊着：“这个操蛋的家伙！”并指着我大骂。然后我看着他绕着屋子走到每一个棋盘前，向他的朋友们讲述刚刚发生的事情。
And like, I can see him pointing at me. I asked the people on the board-- I said, I, don't understand what's going on, you know? Why is he doing this? I don't get what this is about. Like, all I did was stab him. And they're like, uh, you know, you were a little bit out of line. You were a little bit rude.
我可以看见他在指着我。我问棋盘边的其他人——我说：“我不明白发生了什么，你知道吗？他为什么要这么做？我不明白这有什么大不了的。我只不过是捅了他一刀。”他们说：“呃，你知道，你刚才确实有点越界了。你有点粗鲁。”
Or maybe he had not been rude. Maybe he did nothing wrong. Maybe this guy was just pretending to be mad to mess with David's head, pretending to be a hothead, because that image could be useful with all of the other opponents in the coming rounds of the tournament. David had no idea.
或者也许他并不粗鲁。也许他什么都没做错。也许这家伙只是假装生气来干扰大卫的思维，假装自己是个火爆脾气，因为这种形象在锦标赛接下来的几轮中对付其他对手可能很有用。大卫对此一无所知。
So I'm like looking around the room, and I'm realizing, I don't know anybody here. Like, I really felt at that point like I couldn't trust anybody. Then the people in my game who were throwing their arm around me, and be like-- he's just messing with your head, don't worry, come over here and talk to me. You know, I was like-- I don't know how to process this. And I also felt like-- this is too intense. I can't handle this, and I feel so uncomfortable. So I just got up and left and left the tournament.
所以我环顾四周，意识到我不认识这里的任何人。在那一刻，我真的觉得谁都不能相信。后来游戏里那些之前还揽着我肩膀的人，会说——他只是在干扰你的思维，别担心，过来跟我谈谈。你知道，我当时想——我不知道该怎么处理这些。而且我也觉得——这太激烈了。我承受不了，我感觉非常不舒服。所以我直接站起来离开，退出了比赛。
You left?
你离开了？
Yeah. And I never played Diplomacy again after that.
是的。从那以后我再也没玩过《外交风云》。
Years passed. And then he saw that the world Diplomacy championship was going to be in the United States this year. And he thought, maybe he would try to play it one more time and record it for our program. David's a reporter. His full name is David Hill. He usually writes about sports for the website Grantland. And he vowed that this time, playing Diplomacy was going to be different.
几年过去了。然后他看到今年世界外交风云锦标赛将在美国举行。他想，也许他可以再试一次，并为我们的节目做个记录。大卫是一名记者。他的全名是大卫·希尔。他通常为 Grantland 网站撰写体育报道。他发誓这次玩《外交风云》会有所不同。
He knew that he needed a new approach to the game, right, because he couldn't even figure out why other players were reacting to his moves the way that they were. Like, this was a game where you're supposed to stab people in the back, but the way that he was doing it, people were just freaking out. He lacked diplomacy.
他知道自己需要一种新的游戏方法，对吧，因为他甚至搞不清楚为什么其他玩家会对他的举动做出那样的反应。这本就是一个应该在背后捅人一刀的游戏，但他的做法却让人们大惊失色。他缺乏外交手段。
Well, this time, I figured what I really needed was somebody who could teach me tactics, like diplomatic tactics-- you know, the tactics of diplomacy-- so that I could go into the game confident that I was playing correctly, that I wasn't making any mistakes. So I found somebody who could sort of be my coach.
嗯，这次我想我真正需要的是一个能教我战术的人，比如外交战术——你知道，外交的艺术——这样我就能自信地去玩，确保我的操作是正确的，不会犯任何错误。所以我找到了一个可以做我教练的人。
And that person was not a gamer. That person was a diplomat, an actual real life diplomat-- in fact, one that you may have heard of, Dennis Ross, probably best known as President Clinton's Middle East envoy. Dennis Ross brokered the Oslo II Accord. He also helped the George H.W. Bush administration on German reunification back when the wall came down.
那个人不是游戏玩家。那个人是一位外交官，一位现实生活中真正的外交官——事实上，你可能听说过他，丹尼斯·罗斯（Dennis Ross），他最出名的身份可能是克林顿总统的中东特使。丹尼斯·罗斯促成了《奥斯陆协议II》。他还曾在老布什政府时期帮助处理两德统一事宜，就在柏林墙倒塌的时候。
He's been an advisor to President Obama. And in case you're wondering how this man, who's not just brokered international deals, but done it in some of the most contentious conflicts in the world, responded when he was asked to use his expertise and give advice to somebody at the world championship for the board game Diplomacy, well, once it was explained to him what the board game is, his answer was-- sure, sounds like fun.
他曾担任奥巴马总统的顾问。如果你好奇这位不仅促成过国际协议，而且是在世界上一些最激烈的冲突中完成这些任务的人，当被要求运用他的专业知识为这位板棋游戏世界锦标赛的选手提供建议时，会有什么反应？好吧，在向他解释清楚这个棋盘游戏是什么之后，他的回答是——当然，听起来很有趣。
Hi.
你好。
Hey.
嘿。
Nice to meet you. David Hill.
很高兴见到你。大卫·希尔。
Hi, David. Dennis Ross, nice to see you.
你好，大卫。我是丹尼斯·罗斯，很高兴见到你。
So did that feel amazing to have him with you?
那么有他在你身边，感觉是不是很棒？
Yeah. It definitely felt amazing. You know, I felt like I'm back, and this time, I'm going to win, you know, because this time I got the big guns.
是的。感觉绝对很棒。你知道，我觉得我又回来了，这次我一定会赢，因为这次我有强力后盾。
Ambassador Ross apparently took to the game immediately. And we have the story of what happened when David brought his ringer to the fight, when he brought a professional to an amateur match-up. Today, on our program, stories of trying to figure out who has your back and who's looking to stab you in the back and trying to sort out one from the other.
罗斯大使显然立刻就上手了这个游戏。我们接下来要讲的故事，是大卫带上他的重量级援军去迎战，带了一个专业人士去打业余比赛时发生了什么。今天在我们的节目中，我们将讲述那些试图搞清楚谁是你的后盾、谁又打算在背后捅你一刀，以及如何将两者区分开来的故事。
Also, you know, there all the people who want to have your back, who try to have your back, but you are probably making a mistake to depend on them. We talk about that, too. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
还有，你知道，那些想做你后盾、试图帮助你的人，可能依赖他们反而是个错误。我们也会谈论这个。这里是来自芝加哥 WBEZ 的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Absolutely Stabulous. All right. So you have this set up, right. David Hill takes Ambassador Dennis Ross to help him win at a board game tournament. Here is David.
绝对精彩。“好的。所以你有了这样的布局，对吧。大卫·希尔带上了丹尼斯·罗斯大使来帮助他在棋盘游戏锦标赛中获胜。大卫来了。”
The world championship of Diplomacy brought together almost 90 top Diplomacy players from eight different countries. Most of them were middle aged men. All of them were nerds-- and not the Chris Hardwick, Olivia Munn, kind of nerd, homespun nerds-- the real deal-- nerds from all over the world, in a prototypical nerd setting, a basement-- in this case, the dim basement of a dorm at the University of North Carolina in Chapel Hill.
世界《外交风云》锦标赛汇集了来自八个国家的近90名顶尖玩家。他们大多是中年男子。他们全都是极客——不是克里斯·哈德威克或奥利维亚·穆恩那种极客，而是那种纯粹的、老派的极客——真正的极客。来自世界各地，处于一个典型的极客环境里，一个地下室——在这个案例中，是北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校一间宿舍昏暗的地下室。
I strutted into that dorm with diplomat Dennis Ross by my side. I was worried about intimidating the other players. I didn't need to worry. Nobody was scared-- amused maybe. Only one person in this room had counseled four presidents, and everyone's reaction was-- meh. In fact, the tournament director felt he had to rig the game in our favor by assigning me Russia, the strongest of the seven countries on the board. When they announced the assignments, people actually laughed.
我带着外交官丹尼斯·罗斯大步走进那间宿舍。我原本担心会威慑到其他选手。但我不需要担心。没人感到害怕——也许感到好笑。房间里只有一个人曾担任过四位总统的顾问，而每个人的反应是——“没劲”。事实上，锦标赛主管觉得他必须通过分配给我俄罗斯来操纵比赛，俄罗斯是棋盘上七个国家中最强大的。当他们宣布分配结果时，人们甚至笑了。
David Hill.
大卫·希尔。
Russia.
俄罗斯。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So what I want you to do--
所以我想要你做的是——
I quickly lost my confidence. Who was I kidding? I was up against the best in the world, and I would only had an ambassador in my corner for the first game on the first day of a three day tournament. So I decided all I wanted to do was to survive to the end of this game, to know that I could do this. I was freaked out. But Dennis Ross was unfazed.
我很快就失去了自信。我在骗谁呢？我要面对的是世界上最棒的选手，而且我只能在三天赛程的第一天第一局比赛中有一位大使坐镇。所以我决定，我只想在这局比赛中活下来，证明我能做到。我当时快吓坏了。但丹尼斯·罗斯却从容不迫。
If you play with such anxiety, everybody is going to know it.
如果你带着这种焦虑去玩，每个人都会看出来的。
Yeah.
嗯。
They're going to read it. You know, when I was negotiating, I could read the body language. I could tell if someone was really nervous. I once had, in one negotiation, I explained to somebody what it is we needed. And it was clearly way beyond what they thought we were going to go for. And my first impulse was looking at this person-- this [INAUDIBLE] should never play poker. I mean, he literally blanched. So you know, the other thing is you've got to be cool.
他们会读懂的。你知道，当我在谈判时，我能读懂肢体语言。我能看出某人是否真的很紧张。有一次，在一次谈判中，我向对方解释了我们需要什么。这显然远超出了他们认为我们会要求的程度。我当时的第一直觉是看着这个人——这个[听不清]根本不该玩扑克。我的意思是，他字面意义上脸都白了。所以你知道，另一件事是你要保持冷静。
Sure.
当然。
Right?
对吧？
Got it. Got to have a poker face, convey confidence, even if I don't feel it.
明白。我得有张“扑克脸”，传达自信，即使我心里没底。
Right.
没错。
Seven of us gathered around the board. We nodded brief hellos, put 15 minutes on the clock, and bam-- time to negotiate. Since I was big bad Russia, I was instantly the most popular person in the room. All the other players started, well, flirting with me.
七个人围坐在棋盘旁。我们点头简单问候，设定了15分钟的时间，砰——该谈判了。因为我是强大的俄罗斯，我立刻成了房间里最受欢迎的人。所有其他选手都开始，嗯，跟我套近乎。
So hi, Russia. How are you doing?
嘿，俄罗斯。你还好吗？
Hi. I'm good, I'm good. How are you?
嘿。我挺好，挺好。你呢？
Are you figuring out the swing [INAUDIBLE].
你在盘算[听不清]吗。
A little bit, little bit.
一点点，一点点。
That was Austria. Next was Germany.
那是奥地利。接下来是德国。
So if you wanted to work with me against England next year, I'd be very happy to help you by cutting them off, say, from Denmark, or whatever else it is that you need.
所以，如果你明年想和我联手对付英国，我会很乐意帮你，比如从丹麦截断他们，或者任何你需要我做的事情。
Italy.
意大利。
What I want to do is get into a three on one fight. Right? I want to, you and me, and either Turkey or Austria.
我想做的是进行三对一的战斗。对吧？我想，你和我，还有土耳其或奥地利。
OK.
好的。
And Turkey. Russia and Turkey often ally with each other in this game. The shorthand for their alliance is RT. Here's Turkey.
还有土耳其。俄罗斯和土耳其在这个游戏中经常结盟。他们盟约的缩写是 RT。这是土耳其。
RT is probably my favorite alliance on the board.
RT 可能是我在棋盘上最喜欢的联盟。
Mhm.
嗯。
So--
所以——
OK.
好的。
I mean, no matter what happens, you know, when I start with the two way, I'm sticking with you.
我是说，无论发生什么，你知道，当我开始这种双边合作时，我会一直支持你。
Right. But then I am vulnerable if you cooperate with Austria, then, right? Then you could push me out of Russia-- that's the thing that I--
对。但如果我和奥地利合作的话，我就处于弱势了，对吧？那样你就可能把我赶出俄罗斯——这是我担心的——
That is not going to happen.
那是不可能发生的。
Oh, sure. I understand.
哦，当然。我理解。
No. I mean, that is not going to happen. I am sticking with you.
不。我是说，那是不可能发生的。我会一直支持你。
OK, cool.
好的，酷。
Everyone was pretty convincing, I have to say. I didn't know who to believe or who to trust. But Dennis didn't hesitate. For him, it was just another day at the office. He took me into the hallway to confer.
必须说，每个人都相当有说服力。我不知道该相信谁或信任谁。但丹尼斯毫不犹豫。对他来说，这只是工作中的又一天。他带我到走廊商量。
I think Germany is playing a long game. And is just asking you-- he's doing it in a very clever way.
我觉得德国在下一盘大棋。他只是在问你——他用的方式非常聪明。
Right.
对。
The same with Italy. He's doing it in a way where it doesn't look like he's trying to ask you to do things, when he actually is asking you to do something. And the Turkish player, I think, is the one guy who is committed to you in a way that, I think, is most convincing.
意大利也是一样。他采取的方式让你看起来不像是他在请求你做事，而实际上他就是在请求你做某事。而土耳其选手，我认为是唯一一个以最令人信服的方式向你承诺的人。
Dennis said that Turkey reminded him of someone, someone named Sergey Tereshchenko. Tereshchenko was the Soviet Foreign Minister's Chief Assistant. When Dennis first met Tereshchenko, he knew he was going to have to work with him on the issue of German reunification, but he wasn't sure if he could trust him.
丹尼斯说土耳其让他想起了一个人，一个叫谢尔盖·捷列先科的人。捷列先科是苏联外交部长的主管助理。当丹尼斯第一次见到捷列先科时，他知道自己必须在德国统一问题上与他共事，但他不确定能否信任他。
Early on, he said to me-- at a certain point, he said, look the future of my country depends upon a different kind of relationship with the United States. And the way he said it to me made me feel like it wasn't a manipulation. The way he said it was almost exactly the way the person who is playing Turkey conveyed-- I'm going to be there. Even the inflection was the same. I mean, for me, it's like I had this memory, sort of, flash before me, as I listened to him say it and the way he said it.
早些时候，他对我说——在某个时刻，他说，听着，我国家的未来取决于与美国建立一种不同的关系。他对我说的语气让我觉得这不是一种操纵。他说话的方式几乎和玩土耳其的那个人一模一样——“我会支持你”。甚至语调都一样。我的意思是，对我来说，听着他这么说，以及他说话的方式，我感觉就像有一段记忆闪回到了我面前。
Sold. I allied with Turkey. This turned out to be smart. Later in the game, there were plenty of moments where I simply had no idea what the hell was going on. But Turkey knew what he was doing, and he had an interest in keeping me alive.
成交。我与土耳其结盟了。结果证明这是明智的。后来在比赛中，有很多时刻我根本不知道发生了什么鬼。但土耳其知道他在做什么，而且他有兴趣让我活着。
Since you're my number one ally, I'll just tell you, if you go down, I go down. I mean, you are critical to me. I mean, you have to be able to defend yourself.
既然你是我的头号盟友，我就告诉你，如果你倒下了，我也就完了。我的意思是，你对我至关重要。我的意思是，你必须能够保护自己。
Can you give me the supply side of this so that I can make it a build?
你能给我这一侧的供给吗，让我能进行建设？
Oh.
哦。
In the fall-- not now, but in the fall.
在秋天——不是现在，但在秋天。
I'm not ruling it out, actually, because I need for you not to collapse up here.
其实我不排除这种可能性，因为我需要你在这里不要崩溃。
As the game unfolded, everyone was going after Italy, everyone but me. So Italy came over for a chat.
随着游戏的展开，每个人都在针对意大利，除了我。所以意大利过来找我聊天。
What do you want to have happen over the course of the next two years? My long term plan would be for you and I and Turkey to kill Austria, and then, you and I to kill Turkey.
你希望在未来两年里发生什么？我的长期计划是：你、我和土耳其杀死奥地利，然后，你和我再杀死土耳其。
It was a tempting offer, and I was flattered. Italy was one of the best players on the board, a former world champion, named Chris Martin. But saying yes to Italy meant turning against Turkey, and Turkey had been a loyal ally. So Dennis said no. It's like they say. You've got to dance with the one that brung you.
这是一个诱人的提议，我受宠若惊。意大利是棋盘上最厉害的选手之一，一位名叫克里斯·马丁的前世界冠军。但答应意大利意味着背叛土耳其，而土耳其一直是一个忠实的盟友。所以丹尼斯说不。就像他们说的。你得和那个带你来的人一起跳舞。
I still think that, even though Italy is clearly the stronger player, Turkey is a more reliable player.
我依然认为，尽管意大利显然是更强的玩家，但土耳其是一个更可靠的玩家。
I was still so nervous, I kept out of the fighting for as long as I could. I watched Germany and England turn on France and eliminate him from the game. I couldn't stall forever. I knew that eventually I'd have to go to war. I just didn't know who I should fight. But Dennis watched me talking to Germany, who bears a more than passing resemblance to Jason Statham. I was so anxious, you could hear me tapping my lapel mic with a pen.
我还是太紧张了，我尽量长时间地置身于战斗之外。我看着德国和英国联手对付法国，并将其淘汰出局。我不能永远拖延。我知道最终我必须加入战争。只是不知道我应该去和谁打。但丹尼斯看着我和德国人交谈，那个家伙长得非常像杰森·斯坦森。我当时太焦虑了，你甚至能听到我用笔敲击衣领麦克风的声音。
All right. I promise you I'm won't go after any of those four regions.
好吧。我向你保证我不会去进攻那四个区域中的任何一个。
This turn.
这回合。
Absolutely. I can't promise what's going to happen in two or three turns' time, at this time.
绝对。我无法保证两三个回合后会发生什么。
I understand that.
我理解。
But it's at least a promise of a commitment that I can make, this turn.
但这至少是我这回合能做出的承诺。
OK.
好的。
I can't say further than that.
我无法说得更远了。
OK,
好的。
Dennis' evaluation?
丹尼斯的评估？
Look, what he told you is he's not doing anything this time. But what he also told you, basically--
听着，他告诉你的是他这次不会做任何事。但他也基本告诉了你——
He didn't know what he could do later.
他不知道以后能做什么。
Well, what he is telling you is he is going to do it later. That's what that meant.
好吧，他在告诉你他以后会那么做。这就是它的意思。
Yeah.
是的。
So I declared war on Germany and advanced on Munich.
所以我对德国宣战，并向慕尼黑进军。
Munich.
慕尼黑。
He went to Munich. He's attacking me.
他去了慕尼黑。他在攻击我。
Cheeky.
厚颜无耻。
Later, Germany told me this was a great move. Maybe that explains why he was so ticked off about it when I did it.
后来，德国人告诉我这是一个很棒的举动。也许这就是为什么我做的时候他那么生气的原因。
I've never lied to you. From now on, you can't rely on that. What you're doing is you're encouraging me to attack you.
我从未对你撒谎。从现在起，你不能再指望这一点了。你这样做是在鼓励我攻击你。
I understand that. But I would like to say that I haven't lied to you either.
我明白。但我得说，我也没有对你撒谎。
You wouldn't-- yeah, OK, fair enough.
你不会——是的，好的，公平地说。
Lying is something Dennis had very strong feelings about, and his feeling was never do it, ever.
撒谎是丹尼斯非常反感的事，他的感觉是绝对不要撒谎，永远不要。
You don't lie in real diplomacy, because it always comes back to haunt you. Anyone you're dealing with now, you know, they're not going to go away. And so once you lie, that's always there. You don't lie.
在现实外交中你不能撒谎，因为这总是会回来折磨你。你现在打交道的任何人，你知道，他们不会离开。所以一旦你撒了谎，它就一直存在。你不能撒谎。
He also told me that overall, I should keep my attitude in check-- no bullying, no badgering. This is just what I wanted to hear. My experience with playing cutthroat, like, when I blackmailed my friend or got cussed out in that creepy mansion, always ended badly. I was relieved to hear there was a way to be good at diplomacy without making everyone hate me in the process.
他还告诉我要整体控制好自己的态度——不要霸凌，不要没完没了。这正是我想听到的。我玩这种残酷游戏的经历，比如勒索我的朋友，或者在那座令人毛骨悚然的豪宅里被骂，总是以糟糕的结局收场。我很欣慰能听到一种既能玩好《外交风云》又不必让所有人都恨我的方法。
Piedmont holds. [INAUDIBLE] supports Munich. Vienna supports Bohemia. Budapest to Romania--
皮埃蒙特防守。[听不清]支援慕尼黑。维也纳支援波西米亚。布达佩斯向罗马尼亚——
After five or six hours, it got to the point where there were two major alliances, each one taking up about half the board. What that meant was a stalemate-- a six way draw, and we'd all have to split the points for the game. I was fine with that. So were the other people in my alliance.
五六个小时后，情况演变成两个主要联盟，每一个都占据了大约一半的棋盘。这意味着僵局——六方平局，我们都得平分积分。我对此没意见。我联盟里的其他人也一样。
But the other side wanted more points. More points would give them a better shot at winning the world championship. So they pulled each person from my side into the hall, one by one. And they offered each of us a deal to stab our friends.
但另一方想要更多的分数。更多的分数会让他们有更好的机会赢得世界冠军。所以他们把我们这边的人一个一个拉到大厅里。并向我们每个人提供了一个出卖朋友的交易。
When Italy returned from his meeting in the hallway, they followed him back in the room, still hassling him. They went up one side of him and down the other, until he snapped.
当意大利从大厅的会议中回来时，他们跟着他回到房间里，继续骚扰他。他们轮番对他进行攻击，直到他爆发了。
You're going to hold us hostage to a possible point where you knock us down to here.
你们要绑架我们，甚至到了要把我们打压到这里的地步。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[声音重叠]
No, no. Look they cut me out. I don't care. No, shut up. I'm going to talk. OK? You're going to hold us hostage for five hours while you grind down, and you still can't cut us out, right? Because there's a 13th center standing line that all of us can get behind.
不，不。听着，他们把我排除在外。我不在乎。不，闭嘴。我要说话。好吗？你们要把我们扣为人质五小时，一边耗着，却还是不能把我们踢出去，对吧？因为有一条大家都支持的第13个中心的防线。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[声音重叠]
Everyone in the room took a step back. This was the first time tonight any of us had seen Italy show any kind of anger. And it occurred to me, is he faking this as a tactic? Dennis had said anger was a good tool, but only if you use it sparingly.
房间里的每个人都后退了一步。这是今晚我们第一次看到意大利表现出任何愤怒。我突然想到，他是为了战术而假装生气吗？丹尼斯曾说愤怒是个好工具，但只有在你谨慎使用时才有效。
If you use it all the time, it has no effect. And if you want it to have an effect, it has to, in a sense, have drama to it.
如果你一直使用它，它就没效果了。如果你想让它有效，它在某种意义上必须带点戏剧性。
Italy was down to a single army. He was a dead man walking if the game didn't end soon. This was a smart time to get mad, and it was working.
意大利只剩下一支部队。如果比赛不尽快结束，他就是一个死人了。这是个发火的明智时机，而且确实管用。
Can I finish my fucking sentence?
我能把我的操蛋句子说完吗？
Well, I have now finished my sentence, so of course you may.
好吧，我现在说完了，所以当然可以。
OK. It's one turn. I want to see the fall played out.
好的。这只是一回合。我想看到秋季的走势。
Our opponents agreed to only go one more turn before conceding to a draw. Nobody broke. Just like Dennis advised, Turkey and I stuck together to the very end with our new allies, Italy and Austria, and the game was over.
我们的对手同意在认输平局之前再走一回合。没有人背叛。就像丹尼斯建议的那样，土耳其和我与我们的新盟友意大利和奥地利一直坚持到了最后，游戏结束了。
Yay.
耶。
Yay. It's over.
耶。结束了。
It's over? Good game.
结束了？好游戏。
It was just like I'd hoped. I survived. I got through the first game, a draw, with the best players in the world. Before he left, Dennis Ross said farewell to our opponents.
这正如我所希望的那样。我活了下来。我以一场平局完成了第一局比赛，对抗的是世界上最棒的选手。在离开之前，丹尼斯·罗斯向我们的对手告别。
I want to tell you how much I was impressed by this. It's not every day that a diplomat sees people who have a kind of instinct for what real diplomacy is. You guys do it as if you're breathing. It's like breathing oxygen for you. And notwithstanding some obvious differences between the real world and this, I still think that all of you would be good in the reality of diplomacy, not just in the game of it.
我想告诉你们，这给我留下了多么深刻的印象。外交官并非每天都能见到拥有这种真正外交本能的人。你们做起来就像在呼吸一样自然。这就像呼吸氧气一样。尽管现实世界与此存在明显的差异，但我仍然认为你们所有人都适合现实的外交工作，而不仅仅是在游戏中。
Austria pipes up-- so are you hiring?
奥地利插话道——那么你们在招聘吗？
So are you hiring?
那么你们在招聘吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I have a card.
我有张名片。
Thank you so much for your comments.
非常感谢你们的评论。
The good vibes died there. Day two, Dennis was gone. And without him, everything went to hell. My opponents weren't polite or patient anymore. People admitted they'd been nicer when Dennis was around. I think they might have wanted to show the diplomat just how diplomatic they could be. There were fewer attacks and stabs than usually happen-- but that was yesterday.
良好的氛围到此为止。第二天，丹尼斯走了。没有了他，一切都变得一团糟。我的对手不再客气或耐心了。人们承认当丹尼斯在场时他们会更友善。我想他们可能只是想向这位外交官展示他们能有多么“外交”。攻击和背叛比平时少——但那是昨天的事。
You fucked it up, right? I mean, Austria really boned the game of Russia. He boned my game.
你搞砸了，对吧？我的意思是，奥地利真的坑了俄罗斯的游戏。他坑了我的游戏。
Day two was Lord of the Flies . I stuck with the principles Dennis gave me-- pick an ally and stick with him, don't lie. But it was just like in that weird mansion. I felt like everyone was mad at me. And this time, they all told me I wasn't vicious enough. This time they all wanted me to stab my ally. They laughed in my face and told me I was a fool. Everybody stabs, they said. That's part of the game.
第二天就像《蝇王》。我坚持丹尼斯给我的原则——选定一个盟友并支持他，不要撒谎。但这就像在那个奇怪的豪宅里一样。我感觉每个人都在生我的气。这次，他们都说我不够恶毒。这次他们都想让我出卖我的盟友。他们当面嘲笑我，说我是个傻瓜。每个人都会背叛，他们说。那是游戏的一部分。
I refused, and the gloves came off. Are you going to be paid for writing this story, a burly Scottish player asked me? Because I'm losing three day's wages to be here so that I can get screwed by you. He told me I wasn't just playing badly, I was ruining the game for everyone. I got mad, and not in the smart, strategic, kind of way.
我拒绝了，于是冲突升级了。你写这个故事是有报酬的吗，一个健壮的苏格兰选手问我？因为我损失了三天的工资来这里，结果被你坑了。他告诉我我不仅玩得烂，我还毁了所有人的游戏。我生气了，而且不是那种精明的、战略性的生气。
Let me submit this to you. Perhaps, maybe your failure in this game was that you didn't do very good diplomacy with me or with Germany. That's your failure, not mine. So maybe that's why I'm tired of people telling me that I fucked the game up or that I should play differently, when maybe, you should play differently, and you should diplome better.
让我告诉你。也许，你在这场比赛中的失败是因为你没能和我或者德国人进行很好的外交。那是你的失败，而不是我的。所以也许这就是为什么我厌倦了人们告诉我我搞砸了游戏，或者我应该有不同的玩法，而也许，你才应该有不同的玩法，你才应该做得更“外交”。
Eventually my ally, a high school math teacher named Brian, ended up stabbing me. He watched me go to the mat with the other players to defend him, then he chopped me out of the game for a few extra points. I was incredulous. I pulled him aside and asked him why he sold me out. He said, I guess I'm just a hard motherfucker like that, and turned and walked away.
最终，我的盟友，一位名叫布莱恩的高中数学老师，出卖了我。他看着我为了捍卫他而与其他选手争得头破血流，然后为了几点积分把我踢出了游戏。我简直不敢相信。我把他拉到一边问他为什么要出卖我。他说，我想我就是这种硬骨头，然后转身走开了。
I am not a hard motherfucker, not even in a game. I really wanted to play the game of diplomacy using actual diplomacy, being respectful and truthful, and it didn't work. I felt frustrated and angry. And my only consolation was-- at least Dennis Ross thought I'd make a good diplomat. I mean, that's what he told me, so who cares what these nerds think.
我不是个硬骨头，即使在游戏里也不是。我真心想用真正的外交手段来玩《外交风云》，做到尊重和真诚，但那行不通。我感到沮丧和愤怒。我唯一的安慰就是——至少丹尼斯·罗斯认为我会成为一名优秀的外交官。我的意思是，他是这么告诉我的，所以这些极客怎么想又有什么关系呢。
Hi.
你好。
I didn't win the tournament, Ambassador Ross.
我没赢得比赛，罗斯大使。
You know, I didn't bet the house on you doing that.
你知道，我没指望你能做到。
After I got back home, I called Dennis Ross. I told him what I'd been thinking since the tournament-- that the game seemed to require players to be cutthroat, and it wasn't for me.
回到家后，我给丹尼斯·罗斯打了电话。我告诉他我比赛后一直在思考的事情——这个游戏似乎要求玩家必须冷酷无情，这不适合我。
I do think that you were probably wrong about me, at the end of the day. I think that I'm probably not cut out for the US Foreign Service.
我确实认为你最后对我评价可能是错的。我觉得我可能不适合美国外交服务。
Well, I didn't say you were cut out for the US Foreign Service.
嗯，我没说你适合美国外交服务。
Well, that's what I took away. That was my take-away.
嗯，那是我得出的结论。那是我的收获。
That's how good he is. He never lied to me. He never told me I was cut out to be a diplomat. And somehow, I came away from our conversation believing exactly what I wanted to believe.
这就是他有多厉害。他从没对我撒谎。他从没说过我适合做外交官。但不知何故，我在谈话中相信了我想相信的东西。
David Hill. He wrote more about the world diplomacy championships for Grantland. You can find that at Grantland.com. Or there's also a link to that article at our website, thisamericanlife.org. Coming up, a do-gooder who does not have the back of most of the people who want his help. That's in a minute, from Chicago public radio when our program continues.
大卫·希尔。他为 Grantland 撰写了更多关于世界《外交风云》锦标赛的文章。你可以在 Grantland.com 上找到。或者在我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 上也有该文章的链接。接下来，一个乐于助人的人，却并不支持大多数想寻求他帮助的人。那是片刻之后，我们的节目继续。
This American Life -- I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Got Your Back"-- stories of trusting people to protect and guide you, even in situations where it is not so certain that that is a good idea. We've arrived at Act 2 of our program. Act 2, "By the Waters of Haggle-On." You may have heard this audio on the internet. A guy named Ryan Block called Comcast to cancel his internet service. He wanted to change to a different provider. And 10 minutes into the call, he started recording.
《美国生活》——我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“后盾”（Got Your Back）——关于信任他人来保护和引导你的故事，即使在那些并不确定这是个好主意的场合下。我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“讨价还价的水域”。你可能在网上听过这段音频。一个叫瑞安·布洛克的人打电话给康卡斯特（Comcast）取消他的网络服务。他想换一家服务商。通话十分钟后，他开始录音。
OK. We'd like to disconnect. We'd like to disconnect, please.
好的。我们想切断服务。请帮我们切断服务。
OK. So why is it that you don't want this faster speed? Help me understand why you don't want faster internet?
好的。那么为什么你不想要这个更快的速度呢？帮我理解为什么你不想要更快的网络？
Help me understand why you can't just disconnect us.
帮我理解为什么你不能直接切断我们的服务。
Because my job is to have a conversation with you about-- I mean, keeping your service, about finding out why it is that you're looking to cancel the service.
因为我的工作是和你谈谈——我的意思是，关于保留你的服务，关于找出你为什么要取消服务的原因。
Can you disconnect us by phone? Can you disconnect our service? Yes or no?
你能通过电话切断吗？你能切断我们的服务吗？是还是不是？
But what I'm trying to find out is why don't you want--
但我试图找出的是，为什么你不想要——
Yes or no, can you disconnect our service?
是还是不是，你能切断我们的服务吗？
--the same offer a brand new customer is going to get, faster internet than anyone can provide you? Why don't you want those services?
——新客户能得到的同样优惠，比任何人能提供给你的更快的网络？为什么你不想要这些服务？
Because I'm not interested in your services any longer.
因为我不再对你们的服务感兴趣了。
OK. So you're not interested in the fastest internet in the country?
好的。所以你不想要全国最快的网络？
Nope, not interested.
没错，没兴趣。
OK. Why is that?
好的。那是为什么？
Can you disconnect us by phone? Are you capable, in your system, of disconnecting our service, yes or no?
你能通过电话切断吗？在你的系统里，你有能力切断我们的服务，是还是不是？
This recording goes on and on for eight minutes.
这段录音持续了八分钟。
OK. So you don't want to get service? You don't want something that works?
好的。所以你不想得到服务？你不想使用有效的东西？
No. I guess I don't want something that works.
不。我想我确实不想要有效的东西。
So why don't you want something that's good service and something that works?
所以为什么你不想要优质的服务和有效的东西呢？
I mean, is this like a joke? Did we, like, call-- are you punking us right now?
我是说，这是一个玩笑吗？我们是不是打给了——你现在是在整我们吗？
After this call went viral, someone from Comcast called Ryan block to apologize. At this point, 5 million people have listened to this online. And I think that it is so popular because so many of us have been in some situation like this, where against some company, we feel totally powerless. Well, every other week in The Haggler column in The New York Times , people write in with their unsolvable consumer problems. And then reporter David Segal steps in and takes their side. He has their back. He publicly approaches the company and tries to get them to do the right thing.
在这段通话在网上疯传后，康卡斯特有人联系瑞安·布洛克道歉。目前，已经有500万人在线听过这段录音。我认为它之所以如此受欢迎，是因为我们当中有太多人经历过类似的情况，在面对某些公司时，感到完全无力。好吧，《纽约时报》的“讨价还价者”（The Haggler）专栏每隔一周，人们就会写信进来陈述他们无法解决的消费问题。然后记者大卫·西格尔会介入并站在他们一边。他做他们的后盾。他公开接触公司并试图让他们做正确的事。
I work on behalf of people who have been driven insane by indifference, insane by the experience of knocking on a door, knowing that someone is on the other side of that door, and they will not respond. If you can get those people behind the door to respond, it's like a magic trick. It feels like a magic trick to the reader.
我代表那些被冷漠逼疯的人工作，被那种敲开一扇门、明知门后有人却不回应的经历逼疯的人工作。如果你能让门后的人做出回应，那就像变魔术一样。对于读者来说，感觉就像个魔术。
A while back, David Segal stepped in for a guy-- he said that he had signed up for a free trial of e-greeting cards from a company called Blue Mountain Greeting Cards. The company required his credit card info to give him the free trial, and so he did that, and then he clicked some buttons. And then the next thing he knew, they told him that he was a monthly subscriber. So he tried to cancel, right? This is from his email to David Segal.
不久前，大卫·西格尔为一个男人出面——他说他注册了一个叫“蓝山贺卡”（Blue Mountain Greeting Cards）公司的免费电子贺卡试用。该公司要求他提供信用卡信息以获取免费试用，他照做了，然后点了一些按钮。接着他才知道，他们告诉他他成了一名月度订阅用户。所以他尝试取消，对吧？这是他给大卫·西格尔的电子邮件。
I went back to the Cancel page. But it just said-- we are sorry, but we are unable to process your cancellation request, right now-- end quote. Funny, isn't it, that once you've paid, you can't cancel. I'm out $19.99. Can you get it back? William Potash, Brookline, Mass. So I got in touch with Blue Mountain, and they fixed this problem really quickly.
我回到取消页面。但上面只是说——“很抱歉，我们目前无法处理您的取消请求”——引语完。有趣，不是吗？一旦你付了钱，你就取消不了了。我损失了19.99美元。你能把它拿回来吗？威廉·波塔什，马萨诸塞州布鲁克莱恩。所以我联系了蓝山公司，他们很快解决了这个问题。
So good news, right? David tried to reach the consumer, which he always does for the column. And suddenly, this guy who had been emailing him back and forth for days stopped returning his emails. His column deadline approached. David got a little more frantic.
所以这是好消息，对吧？大卫试图联系消费者，他在专栏里总是这样做。突然，这个和他邮件来回好几天的人停止了回复。专栏截稿日临近了。大卫变得有点抓狂。
And so I just went all out. I was like-- I got research to find his mother in New Jersey. I tried to find out where he worked, just to like, get this information. I need to speak to you. Finally, like late on Thursday night, I get a call from a guy named Phil Potash. And he's like, hey, I understand you're trying to get in touch with me. And I said, yeah, you wrote to me-- William Potash? He said, oh no, I'm not William Potash, I'm Phil Potash. I'm like, who's William Potash? He said, that's my 10-year-old son.
所以我竭尽全力。我像——我做了调研找到了他在新泽西的母亲。我试图找出他在哪里工作，只是为了获取这个信息。我需要和你说话。终于，在周四深夜，我接到了一个叫菲尔·波塔什的人的电话。他说，嘿，我明白你试图联系我。我说，是的，是你写信给我的——威廉·波塔什？他说，哦不，我不是威廉·波塔什，我是菲尔·波塔什。我说，谁是威廉·波塔什？他说，那是我的10岁儿子。
Oh.
哦。
It was a boy who had written me, completely convincingly as an adult. It was this completely-- you know, credit card-- it was written, like, just deadpan as an adult. And I think the kid decided-- I don't want to get on the phone with this guy, because he's going to hear that I'm a 10-year-old boy. I remember sitting with friends saying, like, what could explain why William Potash won't call me back? Let's rack our brains. What could explain this? Please, like--
是一个小男孩写信给我的，完全令人信服地像个成年人。这完全是——你知道，信用卡——它写得就像成年人一样冷静。我想那个孩子决定——我不想和这家伙通电话，因为他会听到我是个10岁的小男孩。我还记得和朋友坐在一起说，什么能解释威廉·波塔什为什么不回我电话？让我们开动脑筋。什么能解释这个？求你了——
And what was your theory?
你的理论是什么？
I had no idea. I remember being completely stunned. And it turned out, he's 10 years old. He doesn't want to talk to me, because he hasn't hit puberty.
我根本不知道。我记得当时完全惊呆了。结果发现，他才10岁。他不想和我说话，因为他还没到青春期。
When you write a column like this, of course, tons of people get in touch, wanting you to take their side and get their backs. And the overwhelming majority, David Segal says, he simply cannot help. Like 95 out of 100, he cannot help, because he says these customers, they're not in their right. They are--
当你写这样的专栏时，当然，成吨的人会联系你，想要你站在他们一边并做他们的后盾。绝大多数，大卫·西格尔说，他根本帮不上忙。就像100个人里有95个，他帮不上忙，因为他说这些顾客，他们并不占理。他们——
People who don't have a legitimate beef. And this is most common with warranties. So they bought something five years ago. It had a three year warranty, The Haggler should step in and get a refund.
那些没有正当理由的人。这在保修条款中最常见。所以他们五年前买了东西。那东西有三年保修期，“讨价还价者”应该介入并获得退款。
Wait, and they understand that? They understand that the warranty ran out two years ago?
等等，他们理解这一点吗？他们理解保修期在两年前就过期了吗？
Yeah. There's a fair amount of that. Here's someone who wanted something from a camera store. And they said, we don't have it. We don't have it in stock anymore. So let's refund your money. And he's like, I don't want a refund, I want the thing that I ordered. And they're like, well, we don't have the thing you ordered, so let us send you your money back. And he writes to me, and is like, can you make them send me the thing that I want? And I'm like, no, they don't have it. Like, what am I supposed to do?
是的。这种情况不少见。这里有人想从相机店买东西。他们说，我们没有。我们没货了。所以让我们退款给你吧。他却说，我不要退款，我要我订的东西。他们说，嗯，我们没有你订的东西，所以让我们把你的钱退回去。他写信给我说，你能让他们把我要的东西发给我吗？我说，不能，他们没货了。我是说，我该怎么办？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I don't really understand how I can help at all. So I mean, I think that this is a big part of my life, just sorting through complaints that aren't really good complaints. Here's one. In January, 2013, we traveled to Myanmar and purchased two wooden statues in a shop in Yangon. That's the least promising start--
我真的不明白我怎么能帮得上忙。所以我的意思是，我认为这是我生活中的很大一部分，就是筛选那些并不是真正好的投诉。这有一个。2013年1月，我们去缅甸旅游，在仰光的一家店里买了两个木雕。这是最没希望的开始——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--to any letter I've ever read, because the idea that The Haggler has any juice in Myanmar is ludicrous.
——是我读过的任何信件中（最没希望的开始），因为认为“讨价还价者”在缅甸有任何影响力是荒谬的。
It's also like--
这就像——
Like some guy in Myanmar, you're going to be-- woo, The New York Times.
就像某个缅甸人，你会——哇，《纽约时报》。
Yeah, I'm going to call them up, and they're just going to start quaking immediately, and be like-- oh, did you see The New York Times? Yeah, we have a refund going, right now, to this person.
是的，我会打给他们，他们就会立刻开始发抖，然后说——哦，你看到了《纽约时报》吗？是的，我们现在就给这人退款。
Do you think that writing the column for five years has made you more sympathetic to companies than you were at the beginning?
你认为写这个专栏五年让你比开始时更同情公司了吗？
Yes.
是的。
Not to the customers.
不是对顾客吗？
Oh, I'm sympathetic to both. I mean, when companies misbehave-- and I see a lot of companies misbehave-- I'm absolutely sympathetic to the customers. But I hear from enough entitled customers to feel sympathy for companies. What you see is the worst of customers and the worst of companies.
哦，我两者都同情。我的意思是，当公司行为不端时——我看到很多公司行为不端——我绝对同情顾客。但我收到的那些拥有“权利感”的顾客的抱怨太多了，所以我对公司也产生了同情。你看到的是最糟糕的顾客和最糟糕的公司。
David Segal of The Haggler column in The New York Times .
《纽约时报》“讨价还价者”专栏的大卫·西格尔。
One Woman Show. There's this woman named, Hamida Gulistani. She advocates for women's rights in Afghanistan, helping women who are being beaten by their husbands or forced into terrible arranged marriages. And doing this work in Afghanistan is just as hard a job as whatever it is that you're imagining when I say those words. And for a few years, when the US presence in the country was at its greatest, she did feel like somebody had her back. She felt safer. She saw some progress.
“单人秀”。有个女人叫哈米达·古利斯塔尼（Hamida Gulistani）。她在阿富汗倡导妇女权利，帮助那些遭受丈夫殴打或被迫进入可怕包办婚姻的女性。在阿富汗做这份工作和你听到这些词时想象的一样困难。在美军驻扎在该国最强盛的几年里，她确实觉得有人做她的后盾。她感到更安全。她看到了一些进展。
But now with the US pulling out, her situation is changing. It's gotten way more dangerous already. We do not have her back in the same way at all. For two and a half years, Kevin Sieff has been the Bureau Chief for The Washington Post in Afghanistan, and he has this story about the change that she is facing. A quick trigger warning, for anybody who needs a trigger warning, that this story does include descriptions of incidents of violence against women. Here's Kevin Sieff.
但现在随着美国撤军，她的处境正在改变。情况已经变得更加危险。我们根本不再做她的后盾了。两年半来，凯文·西夫（Kevin Sieff）一直是《华盛顿邮报》驻阿富汗的分社社长，他有关于她所面临的变化的故事。给需要的人一个快速的触发预警，这个故事确实包含了对针对女性暴力事件的描述。这里是凯文·西夫。
Before the US was there as her ally, Hamida was pretty much on her own, doing a job she invented for herself out of nothing. She had no role models. She completely made the whole thing up. She started doing this in 2005.
在美军成为她的盟友之前，哈米达基本上是孤军奋战，做着一份她从无到有为自己发明的工作。她没有榜样。她是凭空创造了这一切。她从2005年开始做这个。
At the time, she had just gotten a nursing job at a clinic in a place called Ghazni City. It's a sprawl of mostly mud-baked buildings in eastern Afghanistan. At the clinic, Hamida basically had a front row seat to how brutally women were still being treated four years after the American invasion. Patients arrived all the time, in burkas with bruises and broken bones.
当时，她刚在加兹尼市的一个诊所找到一份护士工作。那是阿富汗东部一片大部分由泥砖建筑组成的城市。在诊所里，哈米达基本上是第一视角目睹了美军入侵四年后女性依然遭受的残酷待遇。病人总是源源不断地到来，穿着布卡长袍，身上满是伤痕和骨折。
One day, a pregnant woman showed up at the examination room.
有一天，一名孕妇出现在检查室。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
Hamida convinced her to go to the press. Afghan media outlets have popped up in Ghazni, because of funding from the US. And Hamida thought, a woman speaking out against her husband would be news. Maybe they could use the local media to shame the woman's husband. Maybe they could even get the local Prosecutor's attention.
哈米达说服她去向媒体求助。由于美国的资助，阿富汗媒体机构在加兹尼如雨后春笋般涌现。哈米达想，一名女性挺身而出反对她的丈夫会成为新闻。也许他们可以利用当地媒体让那个女人的丈夫感到羞耻。也许他们甚至能引起当地检察官的注意。
How many calls were you getting? I mean, after this first incident, was your phone just ringing all the time?
你接到了多少电话？我是说，在那第一起事件之后，你的电话是不是一直响个不停？
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
Hamida basically became a one woman emergency response team, a de facto point of contact for women who were abused, forced into marriages, or refused divorces. Her phone number got passed all over Ghazni. She realized she didn't have the legal system on her side, she didn't have local officials on her side, but the Americans were encouraging Afghans to recognize women's rights. And the one tool Hamida had with the media, which she used.
哈米达基本上成了一个人的应急响应小组，一个事实上的受虐待、被迫婚或被拒绝离婚女性的联络点。她的电话号码在加兹尼传遍了。她意识到法律体系并不站在她这一边，当地官员也不站在她这一边，但美国人鼓励阿富汗人承认妇女权利。而哈米达手中唯一的工具就是媒体，她运用了它。
This was something new in Afghanistan. She'd drag along the press when she'd go to see a local Imam in a remote village. The best way to help a woman facing domestic violence was to get the local religious leader involved, so she had a strategy. She'd call the Imam.
这在阿富汗是新鲜事。当她去遥远村庄见当地阿訇时，她会带上媒体记者。帮助遭受家庭暴力的女性的最佳方式是让当地宗教领袖介入，所以她有策略。她会打电话给阿訇。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
With a reporter there, the Imam usually would be helpful.
有记者在场，阿訇通常都会提供帮助。
For cases where women didn't want any media attention, Hamida would just show up at the family's house and ad hoc her way to an intervention. A lot of times, there was a conflict between the woman and her own family, mostly involving arranged marriages. A woman once came to Hamida. She said her father was about to marry her off to a drug addict.
对于那些不想引起任何媒体关注的女性案件，哈米达会直接出现在家人的房子里，通过临时干预解决问题。很多时候，女性与她们自己的家人之间存在冲突，大多涉及包办婚姻。一位女性曾找到哈米达。她说她的父亲准备把她嫁给一个吸毒者。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
What happened to the girl after this case was settled by the Attorney General?
在这个案件被总检察长解决后，那个女孩怎么样了？
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
To a man that she chose to marry?
嫁给了一个她选择的男人？
Nine years after she first started, Hamida still operates pretty much the same way. She keeps track of all of her cases in a gruesome notebook. It's full of pictures she's taken of victims with her digital camera-- handcuffed girls standing in prison, women who have almost been beaten to death. Hamida carries an old black cell phone with her all the time. And it's constantly ringing with calls from women who want her help.
在她开始九年后，哈米达的操作方式几乎没变。她在笔记本上记录了所有的案例，那本子惨不忍睹。里面满是她用数码相机拍下的受害者照片——站在监狱里戴着手铐的女孩，几乎被打死的妇女。哈米达总是随身带着一部老式黑色手机。它不断响起，全是想寻求她帮助的女性打来的电话。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
It didn't take long for the Americans to notice Hamida. They'd hoped to find Afghan women who would take up the cause of women's rights. And here she was, exactly what they were looking for-- someone outspoken, aggressive, and willing to risk her life. So they met Hamida and involved her in meetings with top Afghan leaders.
没过多久，美国人就注意到了哈米达。他们希望能找到愿意承担起妇女权利事业的阿富汗女性。而她就在这里，正是他们要找的人——直言不讳、充满攻击性，并且愿意拿生命冒险。所以他们见了哈米达，并让她参与了与阿富汗顶级领导人的会谈。
She even came to Washington, DC, as part of a State Department program. Now Hamida is a big deal. Lots of Afghans know who she is. See's on the Provincial Council in Ghazni. It's their version of the State Senate. She's also on popular national TV shows all the time, like this one, called The People's Voice .
她甚至作为国务院项目的一部分去过华盛顿特区。现在哈米达是大人物了。许多阿富汗人都知道她是谁。她是加兹尼省议会的议员。这相当于他们的参议院。她还经常出现在受欢迎的国家电视节目中，比如这个节目，叫《人民之声》。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
In one segment, she's wearing eyeshadow, lipstick, and high heels. She's in her 40s, the only woman on a big panel of men. She fields questions from young women in the audience.
在一个片段中，她画着眼影，涂着口红，穿着高跟鞋。她40多岁，是那群男性小组中唯一的女性。她回答观众中年轻女性的问题。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
This woman asks why the Afghan government talks so much about women's rights, but doesn't actually do anything. Why are women still having trouble going to school and being out in public? I asked my translator to tell me Hamida's response.
这名女性问，为什么阿富汗政府总是谈论妇女权利，却实际上什么都不做。为什么女性上学和在公共场合活动依然困难重重？我让我的翻译告诉我哈米达的回答。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
She's one of the few women in Afghanistan willing to criticize the government so publicly on national television. In Hamida's view, what she's doing only seems radical because Afghanistan has changed so much since she was a girl. In the 1970s and '80s, it was a far more liberal place. It was a society dominated by men, but her father would never insult his daughters or humiliate them or beat them. She knew women who wore skirts and sleeveless shirts.
她是阿富汗为数不多愿意在全国电视上如此公开批评政府的女性之一。在哈米达看来，她所做的一切之所以看起来激进，只是因为自她少女时代以来，阿富汗已经发生了翻天覆地的变化。在20世纪70年代和80年代，这里是一个远比现在自由的地方。那是一个男人主导的社会，但她的父亲绝不会侮辱、羞辱或殴打他的女儿。她认识穿裙子和无袖衬衫的女性。
But Hamida remembers when all that changed-- when the Mujahideen took over the country. A rocket hit their house. Her cousin was injured. Everyone was going to the hospital, and her brother stopped her.
但哈米达记得这一切是什么时候改变的——当圣战者接管了这个国家。一枚火箭弹击中了她们的家。她的表亲受了伤。每个人都要去医院，她的兄弟拦住了她。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
Hamida had been helping women in Ghazni for four years when President Obama announced the troop surge in 2009, and many of those soldiers and Marines were dispatched to Ghazni. It's part of the Taliban's heartland. At one point, the province had about 20 American bases and several thousand American troops. For the first time, Hamida had real, physical protection, international attention, and legitimacy in the eyes of her own skeptical government.
2009年奥巴马总统宣布增兵时，哈米达已经在加兹尼帮助女性四年了，而那些士兵和海军陆战队员大多被派往加兹尼。那是塔利班的核心地带。一度，该省有大约20个美国基地和数千名美军。第一次，哈米达获得了真正的物理保护、国际关注以及在她自己持怀疑态度的政府眼中的合法性。
The world's superpower had her back. And it gave her a sense of invincibility. She threw a big celebration in 2010 for Women's Day, and the US Ambassador's wife showed up. US troops came to help with security, and there was a huge turnout-- something that would have been hard to imagine before. Women in Ghazni were often confined to their homes. Things weren't perfect, but they seemed to be moving in the right direction.
世界超级大国做了她的后盾。这给了她一种无敌的感觉。2010年，她为妇女节举办了一场盛大的庆祝活动，美国大使的妻子也出席了。美军前来协助安保，到场人数非常多——这在以前是难以想象的。加兹尼的女性通常被禁足家中。事情并不完美，但它们似乎正朝着正确的方向发展。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
But after just a few years, in 2013, Americans were withdrawing from Ghazni, as a part of the larger plan to end the war. For months now, they've been tearing down bases all over Afghanistan. And when you drive around the country, they already look like ancient artifacts-- sort of like Pompeii, with rusty razor wire. Hamida's American contacts in the province were now suddenly gone. She felt things slipping backwards. And then last August.
但在短短几年后，2013年，作为结束战争大计划的一部分，美国人正在从加兹尼撤出。这几个月来，他们一直在拆除阿富汗各地的基地。当你开车环游全国时，它们看起来就像古老的文物——有点像庞贝古城，带着生锈的铁丝网。哈米达在省内的美国联络人现在突然消失了。她感到局势在倒退。然后是去年八月。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
The police didn't come until after the attack had completely ended. By that time, Hamida's bodyguard and driver were dead. She got lucky. The Taliban wanted to kill her.
警察直到袭击完全结束后才赶到。那时，哈米达的保镖和司机已经死了。她很幸运。塔利班想杀了她。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
The Taliban are now gaining more control in Ghazni. At this point in the withdrawal, the US is mostly focused on training Afghan police and other security forces on how to defeat them. Women's rights have dropped into the background, and more and more Afghan officials don't even give lip service to women's rights. Last year, they tried to pass a law that would have made it legal to stone a woman accused of adultery. A few months later, Parliament tried to make it tougher to prosecute rape cases.
塔利班现在在加兹尼获得了更多控制权。在撤军的这个阶段，美国人主要专注于培训阿富汗警察和其他安全部队如何击败他们。妇女权利已退居背景，越来越多的阿富汗官员甚至连嘴上功夫都不做了。去年，他们试图通过一项法律，将对通奸女性实施石刑合法化。几个月后，议会试图让强奸案的起诉变得更困难。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
Hamida has a folder full of death threats from the Taliban. She's been shot at in a shopping mall. Her daughter was in a car chase on the highway. Hamida is always on edge and changes her house every six months.
哈米达的文件夹里塞满了塔利班的死亡威胁。她在购物中心被枪击过。她的女儿经历过公路上的追车。哈米达总是处于边缘状态，每六个月就搬一次家。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
Just to give you a sense of what Hamida is up against, the main people left in Ghazni to protect her-- the police-- are often the same people she's trying to prosecute. A United Nations report shows that 70% of Afghan female police officers have been sexually abused or harassed by male officers. One of her most disturbing cases recently involved a police officer kidnapping a 13-year-old girl named Nuria, then he gang-raped her with some of his colleagues.
为了让你了解哈米达面临的是什么，加兹尼留下来保护她的主要力量——警察——往往就是她试图起诉的同一批人。联合国报告显示，70%的阿富汗女警遭受过男警察的性虐待或骚扰。她最近最令人不安的一个案件涉及一名警察绑架了一名13岁女孩努里亚（Nuria），然后他与几名同事轮奸了她。
Hamida said the girl's whole body was shaking uncontrollably when they met. Nuria decided to talk to local media. She wanted these guys arrested. So Hamida organized a press conference. She sat next to Nuria at a table set up with microphones and recorders.
哈米达说，女孩见到他们时全身都在无法控制地颤抖。努里亚决定向当地媒体发声。她想让这些人被捕。于是哈米达组织了一场新闻发布会。她坐在努里亚身边，桌子上架满了麦克风和录音机。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
Nuria tells them, I regained my consciousness around midnight. I saw three men, and I was completely naked. I tried to grab my clothes, but I fainted. These men violated me and kidnapped me, and I want the government to provide justice for me.
努里亚对他们说，我在午夜左右恢复了意识。我看到了三个男人，我完全赤身裸体。我试图抓起我的衣服，但我晕倒了。这些人侵犯了我并绑架了我，我希望政府能为我提供正义。
How is she doing now?
她现在怎么样了？
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
She's missing?
她失踪了？
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
You know who the police officers were, and nothing happened to them?
你知道那些警察是谁，而他们什么事都没有？
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
Over the last year or so, the Taliban has ramped up its own campaign against women. They've killed at least six female police officers and other women, as well. Sometimes they videotape their murders. In one video, a woman named Najiba, who was accused of adultery, was shot 13 times, while men cheered in the background.
在过去的一年左右里，塔利班加强了他们自己针对女性的运动。他们至少杀害了六名女警和其他女性。有时他们会录下谋杀过程。在一段视频中，一名叫纳吉巴（Najiba）的通奸指控女性被枪击了13次，同时背景里的男人们在欢呼。
At the same time, Hamida says, she sees signs of progress in surprising places-- like she's getting a lot of phone calls these days from girls who've run away from home who need shelter. What's hopeful about this, she says, is that these girls have gotten a message-- that they have a choice, they don't have to put up with violence.
与此同时，哈米达说，她在令人惊讶的地方看到了进步的迹象——比如最近她接到了很多从家里跑出来、需要避难的女孩打来的电话。她说，这令人充满希望之处在于，这些女孩收到了一个信息——她们有选择权，她们不必忍受暴力。
American officials are hoping Hamida can continue the mission she started even after their departure. One diplomat who's worked with Hamida is Karen Decker. She was the State Department's top official in eastern Afghanistan and used to fly over to Ghazni in a helicopter whenever she wanted to see Hamida.
美国官员希望哈米达能在他们离开后继续她开始的任务。一位曾与哈米达合作过的外交官是凯伦·戴克（Karen Decker）。她是美国国务院在阿富汗东部的高级官员，每当想见哈米达时，她都会坐直升机飞往加兹尼。
I will worry about Afghan women. I worry about the fact that they still have a big fight ahead of them, and the bad times may last a long time. They've got to keep fighting. But it's going to be a hard fight.
我会为阿富汗女性担心。我担心她们面前依然有巨大的斗争，而艰难时期可能会持续很长时间。她们必须继续抗争。但这将是一场艰难的战斗。
Karen left her post in Afghanistan shortly after this interview. She'd been there for two years, going to some of the country's most dangerous districts, where some of her first questions were almost always about women-- could they vote, could they work, could they attend school? Regardless of the answers, she knew the US withdrawal had to continue.
凯伦在这次采访后不久就离开了她在阿富汗的岗位。她在那里待了两年，前往该国最危险的地区，那里她的第一个问题几乎总是关于女性的——她们能投票吗，她们能工作吗，她们能上学吗？无论答案如何，她都知道美国必须继续撤军。
At a certain point, we had to step back, even from women that we knew were out there on the razor edge, trying to do good for Afghan women writ large. We still knew that for sustainable development, we could not continue to sit right next to them and enable their every movement, recognizing that it hurts. It hurts to see that. I think anyone would say the same thing. But we sort of steeled our resolve and said, we've got to stop. Because otherwise, we're going to have to be here forever. They will never stand on their own two feet.
在某个时候，我们必须后退，即使是对于那些我们知道身处刀尖、试图为广大阿富汗女性谋福祉的女性（也是如此）。我们仍然知道，为了可持续发展，我们不能继续坐在她们身边并使能她们的每一个动作，意识到这很伤人。看到这一点很伤人。我想任何人都会这么说。但我们稍微坚定了一下决心说，我们必须停止。因为否则，我们将不得不永远待在这里。她们永远无法靠自己的双脚站立。
When the US does leave, or as the withdrawal continues, what's the plan to continue supporting women like Hamida?
当美国真正离开，或者随着撤军的继续，继续支持像哈米达这样的人的计划是什么？
Well, a year ago, I banned the word "leaving" from the vocabulary of every American who worked for me, because we're not leaving. Our embassy is enduring. Our embassy is enormous. It has one of the largest development budgets in the world. I know what you mean when you ask the question-- and yes, everybody talks about us leaving-- but we're not leaving. We are just not going to be physically present in villages and provincial capitals, which is exactly the way we do business in most of the world.
嗯，一年前，我禁止所有为我工作的美国人在词汇表里使用“离开”（leaving）这个词，因为我们并没有离开。我们的大使馆是长期的。我们的大使馆非常巨大。它拥有世界上最高的开发预算之一。我知道你问这个问题时的意思——是的，每个人都在谈论我们要离开——但我们并没有离开。我们只是不会在村庄和省会城市实体存在，这正是我们在世界上大多数地方做生意的方式。
Here's the thing, though-- every Afghan, including Hamida, has a cell phone. Access to the internet is growing. And we will communicate with people via all kinds of computer-based technologies-- Skype, we do a lot of Skype-- and Hamida is very well connected to us through those mechanisms.
不过有一点——每个阿富汗人，包括哈米达，都有手机。互联网的获取正在增长。我们将通过各种基于计算机的技术与人们沟通——Skype，我们做了很多 Skype——哈米达通过那些机制与我们的联系非常紧密。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
Hamida's internet connection isn't fast enough in Ghazni for Skype. She only speaks Dari. She says, sure, since the bases have closed in her area, American officials and soldiers still try to keep in touch. They send her email. She does understand a little bit of English, but it's not good enough to read those emails.
哈米达在加兹尼的互联网连接速度不够快，无法使用 Skype。她只会说达里语。她说，当然，自从她所在地区的基地关闭以来，美国官员和士兵仍然试图保持联系。他们发电子邮件给她。她确实懂一点英语，但水平还不足以阅读那些电子邮件。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
For safety reasons, Hamida moved her kids out of Ghazni. She sent one to live in Pakistan and three to Kabul. Now, they act like they're the parents. They check in with Hamida frequently, ask how her day went, and just make sure she's OK. Sometimes her son, Solar, tries to stop her from going out on cases, especially at night. He's 13, and her youngest. I used the same interpreter for our interview.
出于安全考虑，哈米达把她的孩子从加兹尼转移走了。她送了一个到巴基斯坦，三个到喀布尔。现在，他们表现得好像他们才是父母。他们经常查看哈米达的情况，问她一天过得怎么样，确保她没事。有时她13岁、也是最小的儿子太阳（Solar）会试图阻止她出去办案，尤其是在晚上。我采访时用了同一个翻译。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
It's not as clear for Hamida's daughter, Frohal. She admires her mom. She wants to be just like her, and she's as progressive as any woman I've met in Afghanistan. When I met her at her house, Frohal wasn't wearing a headscarf. She's a senior in college studying art. She likes sculpting nudes. In a few months, she'll graduate and move back to Ghazni to work with her mom. Frohal told me she recently asked her mom what happens to their family when the Americans are completely gone? Again, I used the same translator.
对于哈米达的女儿弗罗哈尔（Frohal），情况就不那么明朗了。她崇拜她的妈妈。她想变得和她一模一样，而且她是我在阿富汗见过的女性中最开明的。当我在她家见到她时，弗罗哈尔没戴头巾。她是学习艺术的大四学生。她喜欢雕刻裸体像。几个月后，她将毕业并回到加兹尼与她妈妈一起工作。弗罗哈尔告诉我，她最近问她妈妈，当美国人彻底离开后，她们家会发生什么？我再次用了同一个翻译。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
Right now, when Hamida thinks about the future, she vacillates between two extremes. She can double down and run for Parliament next year. If she won a spot, she'd finally have some real power over Afghanistan's laws. But it would also make her an even bigger target for the Taliban.
目前，当哈米达思考未来时，她在两个极端之间徘徊。她可以加倍努力，明年竞选议会。如果她赢了一个席位，她最终会对阿富汗的法律有真正的权力。但这也会使她成为塔利班更大的目标。
Or she could openly admit to her American contacts that she needs help getting out of the country. Hamida keeps their business cards in a special drawer in her desk. She's already thinking about asking him for visas for her kids. We talked for hours before she told me this. She was embarrassed.
或者她可以公开向她的美国联络人承认，她需要帮助离开这个国家。哈米达把他们的名片放在办公桌的一个特殊抽屉里。她已经在考虑向他们申请孩子的签证了。我们谈了几个小时，她才告诉我这件事。她感到难为情。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
Does that ever make you want to quit?
那会让你想放弃吗？
[SPEAKING DARI]
[用达里语说话]
For now, though, in public, Hamida still plays the part of a confident Afghan woman. She wants women to feel like they still have an advocate. And so every time her cell phone rings, she takes the call, and when needed, heads out the door.
不过目前，在公共场合，哈米达依然扮演着自信的阿富汗女性的角色。她希望女性们觉得她们依然有拥护者。所以每当她的手机响起，她就会接听，并在需要时走出房门。
Kevin Sieff is a foreign correspondent for The Washington Post . Thanks to his interpreter, Shafi Sharifi.
凯文·西夫是《华盛顿邮报》的外国通讯员。感谢他的翻译沙菲·沙里菲（Shafi Sharifi）。
[MUSIC - "GOT YOUR BACK" BY MATT THE ELECTRICIAN]
[音乐 - 马特·电工的《后盾》]
Our program was produced today by Chana Joffe-Walt, myself, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Sarah Keonig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robin Semien, Alyssa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from JP Dukes. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Research help from Michelle Harris and Julie Beer. Music help from Rob Geddis.
我们的节目今天由查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）和我制作，亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、斯蒂芬妮·富（Stephanie Foo）、萨拉·凯尼格（Sarah Keonig）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robin Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alyssa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）参与。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。JP·杜克斯（JP Dukes）提供制作帮助。塞思·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。伊莉丝·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的办公室经理。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨（Adrianne Mathiowetz）负责我们的网站。米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）和朱莉·比尔（Julie Beer）提供研究帮助。罗布·格迪斯（Rob Geddis）提供音乐帮助。
Thanks, today, to Mohammad Sharif, Arash Afghahi, Sonya Ryda, Barya Schechter, David Hood, Chris Martin, Steve Cooley, Toby Harris, Andy Bartoloni, Siobhan Nolan, Mark Stegman, Aaron Duncan, Eric Monte, Greg Legoretta, and Emanuel Ruffler, of Mac Tech.
感谢今天穆罕默德·沙里夫（Mohammad Sharif）、阿拉什·阿富加希（Arash Afghahi）、索尼娅·里达（Sonya Ryda）、巴里亚·谢克特（Barya Schechter）、大卫·胡德（David Hood）、克里斯·马丁（Chris Martin）、史蒂夫·库利（Steve Cooley）、托比·哈里斯（Toby Harris）、安迪·巴托洛尼（Andy Bartoloni）、西沃恩·诺兰（Siobhan Nolan）、马克·斯特格曼（Mark Stegman）、亚伦·邓肯（Aaron Duncan）、埃里克·蒙特（Eric Monte）、格雷格·莱戈雷塔（Greg Legoretta）和 Mac Tech 的伊曼纽尔·鲁夫勒（Emanuel Ruffler）。
A water pipe burst last night in our computer room, here at the radio show. The only reason that we actually have a new program today is Emanuel swooping in after midnight to pull the audio off of water-soaked computers. He had our back. He saved the day. Our website-- thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
昨晚在我们的无线电节目广播室，我们的计算机机房里水管爆裂了。今天我们之所以还能有一期新节目，唯一原因就是伊曼纽尔在午夜后迅速赶来，从被水浸泡的电脑里抢救出了音频。他做了我们的后盾。他挽救了局面。我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心 PRX 投送到各个公共电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who describes his efforts rallying everybody who pitches on air during the pledge drive this way--
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生，他这样描述他在捐款活动期间动员所有上台呼吁筹款的努力——
I work on behalf of people who have been driven insane by indifference, insane by the experience of knocking on a door, knowing that someone's on the other side of that door, and they will not respond.
我代表那些被冷漠逼疯的人工作，被那种敲开一扇门、明知门后有人却不回应的经历逼疯的人工作。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "GOT YOUR BACK" BY MATT THE ELECTRICIAN]
[音乐 - 马特·电工的《后盾》]